[Music]
last week the pepsi company cut their
ties with rap star lil wayne
because one of his new songs contains
controversial lyrics
yeah
well one of our writers on the show has
been following this story very closely
and he said he wants to share his
opinion about this whole scandal with
little wayne and pepsi please welcome
deon cole
[Music]
thanks conan yeah i got an opinion about
this but i don't want to be the angry
black guy coming out here talking about
lil wayne in his situation so instead
i'm going to let the whitest writer of
the show
come out here and read what i wrote so
everybody welcome brian kyle
[Applause]
thanks conan
hey pepsi
as a righteous black man i'm offended at
how you treated my dog lil wayne
i mean who did you think you was getting
will smith
is this your first time hearing a lil
wayne album
so his other lyrics didn't bother you
lyrics like
i'll let my goons rush you like moscow
gun at your eyebrow
pow pow
or
i'm on that good kush
and alcohol
i got some down [ __ ] i can call
come on pepsi
you hire a gangster you're gonna get a
gangsta
anyway
now that you fired lil wayne you must be
looking for another cool
hip young black man
who can reach your market
look no further
i will pimp
the [ __ ] out of that mountain dew
[Applause]
ryan that's great
brian kylie and uh dion cole everybody
yeah well i'm sorry what is it brian um
actually i have something i want to say
but it's so white
i'd like to have dion say it for me is
that okay dion
uh okay
[Applause]
so last week i went to a michael buble
concert
it was picnic seating and each and i
tried to bring a bottle of white wine
but they took it from me because glass
wasn't allowed well sir that really got
my dockers in a bunch
i said that's ridiculous they let me
bring chardonnay to the david sedaris
reading
[Laughter]
thank you very much gentlemen thank you